So the answer is 1 seventh, which is
pretty good. There aren't many things that we
deal with where we can think of them in terms of fractions of the speed of light
and fractions above 10%. So our data was
traveling between California and Massachusetts at a speed of
about 43,000 kilometers per second. And most of
that time is not the time on the wire.
While the data's traveling on the wires, it's traveling pretty close to
the speed of light. The speed of light through optical fiber is about
50% slower than light travels in a vacuum. But what's taking up
most of the time is all the routers that it had to go
through. And we saw that, from the traceroute, that it went through
about 20 routers. So each of those routers had to take a packet
in, figure out where to send it, and do all that in the
time that it had to travel across the country, which was a 100
milliseconds total, so the average speed going across the country
was one seventh the speed of light, I can show
you the Python code to compute that. So we have
the distance which is 4300, that's the number of kilometers between
Palo Alto and Cambridge. We have the speed of light,
which is approximately 300,000 kilometers per second. And we have the
time it took, which, since we're using seconds as our
unit for the speed of light, we should put in seconds.
And so it as 100 milliseconds, which is 0.1
seconds. And so I can compute the time it took
light to travel that distance. By dividing the distance by
the speed of light and let's see what that is.
So if it was travelling at the speed of light it
would take 0.014 seconds to get across the country, which is
14 milliseconds. What it actually took was a 100 milliseconds. And
if we divide the time it actually took by the time
it would take light to travel, we get 6.97. So, it's
taking almost seven times as long as it would take if
it was just light traveling in a vacuum for that distance.
If you had a vacuum between Palo Alto and Cambridge and
no routers and nothing else along the way, well then
you could get your packets across about seven times faster than
the internet actually does. Not many people can afford setting up
a dedicated vacuum between the two points they want to communicate.